malgré des expériences très sophistiquées,
il n'existe aucune vraie science derrière tout cela,
parce que toutes ces recherches se heurtent à un problème,
qui est le suivant : personne ne connaît
toutes les odeurs émises par l'homme.
Nous dégageons des centaines de molécules.
Nous sommes des mammifères. Nous produisons quantité d'odeurs.
Personnes ne les a recensées de manière systématique
pour permettre de travailler sur celles qui sont réellement des phéromones.
Toutes les expériences sont basées
sur quelques-unes mises en évidence,
mais rien qui ne permette d'aboutir à des conclusions réelles.
Bien sûr, cela ne veut pas dire
que les odeurs n'ont pas d'importance pour les gens.
Elles le sont, certaines personnes y sont particulièrement sensibles,
Napoléon en est un exemple typique.
Vous devez vous rappeler
qu'au retour d'une campagne,
il écrivait à sa chère et tendre, l'impératrice Joséphine
pour lui dire : « Ne te lave pas. J'arrive. »
(Rires)
Il ne voulait rien perdre de toute sa richesse sensorielle
pendant les quelques jours qui précédaient son retour.
Encore maintenant, vous trouverez des sites
qui vous présentent cela comme une excentricité...
En même temps, pourtant,
nous dépensons à peu près autant d'argent
pour supprimer nos odeurs
que pour nous en couvrir de nouvelles, avec des parfums,
les parfums sont une industrie à plusieurs milliards de dollars.
Ce que je souhaite faire dans cette conférence,
c'est vous expliquer ce que sont réellement les phéromones,
vous dire pourquoi l'on pense
que les humains produisent des phéromones,
vous parler de quelques confusions existantes au niveau des phéromones,
et je souhaite finir en vous parlant
d'un chemin prometteur qui nous montre
vers où nous devrions nous diriger.
Les Grecs anciens savaient
que les chiens pouvaient s'envoyer, entre eux, des signaux invisibles.
Une chienne en chaleur
envoie des signaux invisibles aux mâles
à des kilomètres à la ronde,
et ce n'était pas un bruit, mais une odeur.
Vous pouviez prendre l'odeur de la femelle,
et les chiens courraient après le tissu.
Le problème pour nous tous
qui sommes témoins de cet effet
était l'impossibilité d'identifier la molécule,
de démontrer que c'était chimique.
La raison en est, bien sûr,
que chacun de ces animaux
produit de très faibles quantités.
Dans le cas du chien,
les mâles peuvent sentir cela, mais pas nous.
C'est seulement en 1959 qu'une équipe allemande,
après avoir passé 20 ans à rechercher ces molécules,
a découvert, identifié, la première phéromone,
c'était la phéromone sexuelle du ver à soie.
C'était un choix judicieux, fait par Adolf Butenandt et son équipe,
parce qu'il lui fallait un demi million de vers
pour avoir assez de matière pour faire les analyses chimiques.
Il a créé le modèle
à suivre pour toutes les analyses de phéromones.
Il a étudié de manière systématique
et montré que seule la molécule en question
était celle qui stimulait les mâles,
et aucune autre.
Il a analysé tout cela très attentivement.
Il a synthétisé la molécule,
et ensuite testé la molécule synthétisée sur les mâles,
il a obtenu des réponses de leur part et montré,
que c'était vraiment cette molécule.
La boucle était bouclée.
Cela n'a encore jamais été fait avec les êtres humains :
rien de systématique, pas de vraie démonstration.
Avec ce nouveau concept,
il fallait un mot nouveau,
c'était le mot « phéromone »,
c'est en gros une transmission d'informations sexuelles,
entre les individus.
Depuis 1959, des phéromones ont été trouvées
dans tout le règne animal,
chez les mâles comme chez les femelles.
C'est la même chose sous l'eau
pour les poissons rouges et les homards.
et presque tous les mammifères
ont eu une phéromone identifiée,
et bien sûr, un nombre très important d'insectes.
Les phéromones existent donc
dans tout le règne animal.
Qu'en est-il des humains ?
Pour commencer, bien sûr,
nous sommes des mammifères,
et les mammifères ont des odeurs.
Comme tout chien vous le dirait,
nous sentons, ils sentent.
Nous pouvons penser
que les humains ont des phéromones
à cause des changements qui se produisent quand nous grandissons.
L'odeur d'une chambre d'adolescent
est très différente
de l'odeur d'une chambre d'enfant.
Ce qui a changé ? Bien sûr, c'est la puberté.
Avec les poils pubiens
et les poils sous les aisselles,
de nouvelles glandes commencent à sécréter dans ces endroits,
et c'est ce qui provoque le changement de l'odeur.
Si nous étions n'importe quel autre mammifère,
ou animal
nous dirions :
« Ça doit être quelque chose lié aux phéromones »
et on ferait des recherches adaptées.
Mais il y a quelques problèmes, et c'est là,
je pense, pourquoi les gens n'ont pas cherché
des phéromones aussi efficacement chez l'être humain.
Il y a, en effet, des problèmes.
Et le premier d'entre eux
est peut-être surprenant.
C'est une histoire de culture.
Les vers n'apprennent pas grand chose
concernant ce qu'il est « bien » de sentir, mais les humains si,
et jusqu'à l'âge de 4 ans,
toute odeur, même très rance,
est simplement intéressante.
Et c'est un rôle majeur des parents
d'éviter que leurs enfants mettent leurs doigts dans leur caca,
parce que c'est toujours agréable à sentir.
Mais peu à peu nous apprenons ce qui n'est pas bien,
et l'une des choses que nous apprenons
en même temps que ce qui n'est pas bien
c'est ce qui est bien.
Ainsi, le fromage derrière moi
est une gourmandise britannique, sinon anglaise.
C'est un Stilton bleu qui sent fort.
L'apprécier est impensable pour ceux qui ne viennent pas de ce pays.
Chaque culture a sa nourriture typique
et sa gourmandise nationale.
Si vous venez d'Islande,
votre plat national
est du requin bien pourri.
Donc, toutes ces choses sont des goûts acquis
mais ils sont une carte d'identité.
Vous faites partie de ce groupe.
La deuxième chose, c'est l'odorat.
Chacun d'entre nous a un monde d'odeurs qui lui est propre,
dans le sens où, ce que nous sentons,
est complètement différent pour chaque individu.
L'odorat est l'un des sens
les plus difficiles à appréhender,
et le Prix Nobel remis à
Richard Axel et Linda Buck
n'a été octroyé qu'en 2004
pour leur découverte du fonctionnement de l'odorat.
C'est très complexe,
mais l'idée est que des nerfs du cerveau
entrent dans le nez
et dans les terminaisons nerveuses du nez,
exposées à l'air extérieur, il y a des récepteurs,
et les molécules odorantes qui pénètrent sur l'inspiration
interagissent avec ces récepteurs,
et s'ils se relient, ils envoient un signal au nerf
qui va dans le cerveau.
Nous n'avons pas qu'un type de récepteur.
Chaque humain a près de 400
types de récepteurs,
et le cerveau sait ce que vous sentez
par la combinaison des récepteurs
et des cellules nerveuses qu'elles activent,
envoyant un message au cerveau
d'une manière combinatoire.
Mais c'est un peu plus compliqué,
parce que chacun des 400 types
possède plusieurs variantes,
et suivant la variante que vous avez,
vous pourriez ressentir la coriandre, l'herbe,
comme une sensation délicieuse et savoureuse
ou bien comme quelque chose proche du savon.
Donc chacun de nous a son propre monde d'odeurs,
et ça complique tout
quand nous étudions les odeurs.
Il faut vraiment que nous parlions des aisselles.
Je dois dire que j'en ai des particulièrement bonnes.
Je ne vais pas vous les montrer,
c'est l'endroit où la plupart des gens
ont cherché des phéromones.
Il y a une bonne raison à cela
qui est que les grands singes ont des aisselles
comme caractéristique propre à leur espèce.
Les autres primates ont des glandes odorantes
dans d'autres parties du corps.
Les grands singes ont ces aisselles
pleines de glandes sécrétoires
qui produisent des odeurs tout le temps,
un nombre important de molécules.
Quand elles sont sécrétées par les glandes,
les molécules n'ont pas d'odeur.
Elles ne sentent rien du tout,
et seules les extraordinaires bactéries
qui croissent dans la forêt de poils
produisent en fait les odeurs
que nous connaissons et aimons.
Donc entre parenthèses, pour réduire
les odeurs,
se raser les aisselles
est un moyen très efficace de réduire
l'habitat des bactéries,
et vous verrez qu'elles resteront moins odorantes
bien plus longtemps.
Bien que nous nous soyons focalisés sur les aisselles,
je pense que c'est surtout
parce que c'est moins embarrassant pour demander des échantillons.
Il y a une autre raison qui fait que nous ne devrions pas
chercher une phéromone universelle du sexe à cet endroit,
et c'est que 20% de la population mondiale
n'a pas des aisselles odorantes comme les miennes.
Il s'agit des habitants de la Chine, du Japon,
de la Corée et d'autres parties du l'Asie du Nord-Est.
Ils ne secrètent tout simplement pas ces précurseurs sans odeur
que les bactéries adorent utiliser pour produire les odeurs
que nous avons crues de façon ethnocentrique
caractéristiques des aisselles.
Donc ça ne concerne pas 20% du monde.
Donc que devrions-nous faire
dans la recherche des phéromones humaines ?
Je suis profondément convaincu que nous en avons.
Nous sommes des mammifères,
comme tous les mammifères, et nous en avons probablement.
Mais je crois que nous devrions
recommencer tout du début,
et en gros chercher partout sur le corps.
Peu importe que ce soit embarrassant,
nous devons chercher et aller pour la première fois
là où personne d'autre n'a osé chercher.
Ce sera difficile,
ce sera embarrassant, mais nous devons chercher.
Nous devons aussi reprendre les idées
que Butenandt avait utilisées quand il étudiait le ver à soie.
Nous devons recommencer et regarder systématiquement
toutes les molécules qui sont produites,
et comprendre lesquelles sont impliquées.
Ça ne suffit pas d'en pointer un groupe
et de dire : « Elles feront l'affaire. »
Nous devons vraiment prouver
qu'elles ont réellement les effets que nous leur accordons.
Il y a une équipe qui m'impressionne vraiment en fait.
Ils sont en France et leur succès précédent
a été d'identifier la phéromone mammaire du lapin.
Ils ont maintenant orienté leur attention
vers les bébés humains et leurs mères.
Ici vous avez un bébé qui boit du lait
de la poitrine de sa mère.
Son mamelon est complètement caché
par la tête du bébé,
mais vous pouvez noter une gouttelette blanche
avec une flèche qui pointe vers elle,
et c'est une sécrétion des glandes aréolaires.
Nous en avons tous, hommes et femmes,
et ce sont les petites bosses autour du mamelon,
et si vous êtes une femme qui allaite,
elles commencent à sécréter.
C'est une sécrétion vraiment intéressante.
Benoist Schaal et son équipe ont développé
un test simple qui étudie
ce que cette sécrétion peut avoir comme effets.
En fait, un simple test biologique.
Ici, vous avez un bébé qui dort,
et sous son nez on a placé une tige propre.
Le bébé reste endormi,
il ne montre pas le moindre intérêt.
Mais si nous prenons chez une mère
qui sécrète dans les glandes mammaires,
il n'y a pas de reconnaissance,
il peut s'agit de n'importe quelle mère,
et nous prenons la sécrétion
et nous la mettons maintenant sous le nez du bébé,
nous obtenons une réaction très différente.
C'est une réaction de délice de connaisseur,
et il ouvre sa bouche
et sort sa langue
et il commence à téter.
Étant donné que cela marche avec toute mère,
ça peut vraiment être une phéromone.
Pas une reconnaissance individuelle.
Toute mère fait l'affaire.
Pourquoi est-ce important,
à part que c'est très intéressant ?
C'est parce que les femmes
ont un nombre de glandes aréolaires très différent,
et il y a une corrélation entre la facilité
avec laquelle les bébés se mettent à téter
et le nombre de glandes de la mère.
Il semble que plus elle a de sécrétions,
plus il est probable que le bébé tète rapidement.
Pour un mammifère,
le moment le plus dangereux dans la vie
ce sont les premières heures après la naissance.
Il faut que vous receviez cette première tétée,
et si vous ne la recevez pas, vous ne survivez pas.
vous mourrez.
Vu que beaucoup de bébés ont dans les faits du mal
à prendre leur premier repas,
parce qu'ils n'ont pas le bon stimulus.
Si nous pouvions identifier cette molécule,
et l'équipe française est très prudente,
mais si nous pouvions identifier la molécule,
la synthétiser, cela signifierait
que les prématurés auraient plus de chance de téter,
et tous les bébés auraient plus de chances
de survie.
Ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est un des exemples
où une approche systématique et vraiment scientifique
peut nous apporter une compréhension réelle
des phéromones.
Toutes sortes d'interventions médicales sont possibles,
toutes sortes de choses
que les humains font avec les phéromones
que nous ne connaissons pas pour le moment.
Nous devons savoir que les phéromones
ce n'est pas que du sexe.
Elles concernent plein de choses
dans une vie de mammifères.
Donc allez de l'avant et cherchez plus.
Il reste beaucoup à trouver.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)